so I'm honored to introduce Secretary
William Perry as our ETL guests today
some of you are going to be lucky enough
to have one distinguished career but dr.
Perry has made all his days count he's
been responsible for preparing us for
war and keeping us at peace some of you
might know dr. Perry is an expert in
u.s. foreign policy national security
and arms control where he might have
seen him here at Stanford as a professor
and senior fellow at the Freeman spogli
Institute and the Hoover Institution and
as a director of the preventive defense
project working to reduce the
proliferation of nuclear weapons some of
you might also know dr. Perry
as the 19th Secretary of Defense or as
Undersecretary of Defense for research
and engineering when he was the father
of the second offset strategy which used
software and semiconductors to build
smart weapons smart sensors and stealth
that helped end the Cold War but for you
engineers and entrepreneurs in the
audience he was one of you a Stanford
graduate and has a PhD in math he was
not only a director of engineering at a
large company GTE Sylvania he then left
it and founded a start-up ESL which was
the first company to combine computers
and signals intelligence his work and
those two companies made him one of the
10 founders of National Reconnaissance
and when he came back from his first
stint in government he moved into
investment banking and venture capital
at Hamburg and Quist and then later as a
founder of Technology Strategy and
alliances now dr. Perry has gotten more
medals and decorations than I could
count and we'd probably be talking all
day if I listed them but I thought it
was incredibly cool that he's a knight
commander of the British Empire that one
kind of I stopped when I read that what
his book my journey at the nuclear brink
is the story of his coming at age in the
nuclear era his role in trying to shape
it and contain it and how his thinking
has changed about the threat of these
nuclear weapons you should all own a
copy so if you want to understand
how scientists and engineers can serve
their country and defense and diplomacy
for me there's no better person to
emulate so please help me welcome
secretary Perry
so mr. secretary I have a first question
I'm not sure you've ever been asked
which is you have a PhD in math why
didn't you become an academic I started
off my ph.d program with the intention
of becoming an academic that my whole
life is a set of accidents when you
think about it I never really planned
what happened to me in my life it just
happened sort of a random walk process
but about halfway through my ph.d
program we had a third and fourth
children there were twins and my GI Bill
had run out and I couldn't live on the
cellar I was making so I went to get a
part-time job to supplement my research
assistantship and it was at the defense
company I found I liked the job I found
I was good at the job and so by the time
I actually finished my graduate school I
applied both to defense companies but
high tech position there and two
universities I got offers to start
universities and I got attackin I sort
of flipped a coin and took the tech
companies that came out probably what
persuaded me was the company that maybe
the offer here I was was in Mountain
View California and I wanted I really
wanted to come back and be near Stanford
so that helped swing them and the real
reason was that I couldn't afford to go
on to finish my PhD without getting a
part-time job and that was in defense
law electronics and I liked it and the
world's better place for that story so a
big company yeah but decided to leave
and start a start-up at the time when
there weren't many startups being
started there was no venture capital or
barely any why didn't first of all what
happened in that company that made you
kind of like decide to get up and leave
well let me set the stage first of all
for this audience which for whom
entrepreneurial activity and starting a
new company is considered the right
thing to do this was back in 1963 before
there was a Silicon Valley who used to
be called Santa Clara Valley beef when
Cupertino and instead of having apple
had apricot orchards and when Mountain
View instead of having Google had truck
farms
I mean you there was so much different
then you can hardly imagine it when you
can buy a lovely new 4-bedroom 2bath
house for twenty five thousand dollars
so the world was very very different
then but in particular people were not
going on starting companies the idea of
a start-up the idea of Stanford graduate
rushing yards Charlie Eppes own company
just unheard of everybody worked 10 15
20 years another kind of really plan to
make the career doing that so you go
back to your question why did I leave I
had a very good job with a very prompt
very good company and two reasons I just
got annoyed by the administrative
apparatus which stood on top made
Sylvania which is the company originally
I'd worked for had been bought by GTE
which is a big electronics company a big
beer meth company and with that came a
whole set of procedures and processes
and just pain in the neck as far as I
was concerned and the second thing that
happened about that time was the digital
age was starting to talk to this
audience the digital age is starting
which seemed harder than imagined but
and just to put in context that all of
the military equipment though they are
99% of new equipment so have vacuum tube
tenant it was a very very different
world but the digital age you could see
was going to change everything I wanted
to introduce that big time into what I
was doing in my laboratory
the parent company Sylvania was the
world's largest manufacturing vacuum
tubes and they understood the time I
could actually go to make it different
they had a semiconductor laboratory
there was very clear to me that they
could not seize that opportunity it's
what I called then the liability of
leadership if a company has a leadership
position in a particular field or a
particular technology and a new
disruptive technology comes around
that coming almost never is able to
seize the new up to even though they see
clearly but the opportunity is it's like
they have to kill their own baby and why
used to do that existing it's a
psychological it's psychological yeah in
the leadership of the couple in the
leadership of the company they they've
so much invested psychologically and in
and financially also in the in their
current products they cannot really
grasp the idea of bringing along a new
product to kill the one that's been
successful for them so what we saw
clearly in Sylvania Sylvania although
they had a semiconductor laboratory had
a head start on all the other companies
were way ahead of Intel I well who has
heard of any of Sylvania semiconductors
lately I mean they just never made it
Intel took took the field the other
another clear example of that time of
liability of leadership was IBM you know
who sees the personal computer field the
largest computer country in the world
IBM or an unknown upstart company called
Apple so I think this is an idea of
liability leadership is very very
important so you worry so I saw that
liability like I want to get out of here
and start my own company pretty
substantial reputation in the
intelligence community and you
participated in Cuba Cuban Missile
Crisis and reviewing intelligence for I
got handed to the president literally
that next hour about what was what was
in Cuba but it was still an incredibly
risky venture how'd you fund it was
there venture capital firms to go to and
it was I never you know I never thought
it was that risky I had so much
self-confidence so we could do it I
suppose that's true of all entrepreneurs
they just believed they can do it who's
gonna who's going to stop them from
doing it
that's like wait but in fact on your
question of venture capital back in 64
when we started the company there was
very little venture capital in the most
together pension capital comes you hear
of the day when he hadn't even been
started by that time there were few and
we went and talked with one of them an
immediate problem was we couldn't tell
much about what we were doing it was all
secret work or who our customers are
going to be
so that those discussion didn't go red
for her which was a good thing because
we decided that instead of going to
outside for money we would raise the
money ourselves we would form not
associate to company that is a company
where employees funded the company but a
pure associates company all employees
had an opportunity to buy starting the
company nearly all of them maybe 95%
exercised that opportunity and we sold
no stock outside the company is about of
policy in the first year we raised about
a million dollars just from employees of
the company and that was enough to fund
the company and then our profit company
was profitable from the first year and
then the ongoing profits funded the
later growth but it was a it was a
situation which is hard to relate to
today the point the main point though
Steve why this turned out to be such an
important decision even more than I
realized at the time was each of the
employees that came to the company
including myself and the other first
founders essentially none of us had over
any any wealth inherited wealth we had a
retirement funded - company we'd worked
for for ten years and so we took our
retirement funds and invested them in
the company so if the company failed it
was not some poor venture capitalist
losing his money
it was each one of the employees life
savings the wealth window Wow that was a
huge incentive believe me a huge
incentive and and when you built the
company there was maybe Fairchild you
have a packard other technology
companies as models what did you decide
to adopt and what did you decide to do
different in building a culture I don't
know that we made such a conscious
decision of doing that and they weren't
we ended up with the very different
culture as you know there was a
google-like culture today but Google did
it consciously with the reason they
thought this is a good way of bringing
in and stimulate employees we stumbled
on to it we stumbled on to a bit cause
we were a company owned by its employees
and so the employees had a lot to do and
say about how the company was run and
managed and that just led to an
environment like a google-like
environment
a couple of examples of what was unique
that was different do you remember it's
hard to point anyone things T but it was
I would say was most of the employees
who worked there would say when pick me
when I left it told me there was like a
family working here people felt a bond
to each other it was collegial I took
part of that bond and I think all of the
went back to the idea that there was a
combined employee owned company it was
their company I have a I had a Navy
captain who was my military aide when I
was a Secretary of Defense and he later
went on to command a ship and his way of
commandment area like anybody would come
to him and say here's a problem what
should I do with it he said it's your
ship it's your ship do what you think
would be best if you owned the ship well
that was sort of attitude in the company
it's your company what's the right thing
to do it's your company do the thing
which you think is best
yeah you've got a few about customers I
remember you transmitted to your
employees about how you treated
customers and how you thought about them
it may be worth sharing with people
today who think that customers exist to
buy products I certainly for our company
and I think for probably most companies
to succeed the leadership of the company
has to identify and associate themselves
with the customers problems and try to
you're there to solve their problems and
if you if you say if you believe that if
you act on that you end up with a very
successful marketing program in a
successful company but you have to
believe it's not just a matter of saying
it had to believe it and then act on it
so for that reason we end up with became
very dedicated customers who understood
the we do we took their problems very
much to heart and they were incredible
to you and I subversive you were doing
things that were normally sometimes the
province of the customer and sitting
side by side with them is we were acting
like the customer sometimes but in it
the customers interest so back to your
days as a land manager inside at
Sylvania and as the CEO of a company
working with these customers
how did you sell and convince others
that some of the non-consensus ideas
that you had for products or ideas made
sense when everybody wanted to go down
the better version of existence you
remember ever having any of those
conversations and yes yeah because you
were great at it I mean obviously you
have its record of being successful
selling disruption basically the
technical idea of starting the company
was this sees the new products coming
out of the digital field the new
semiconductors and develop products in
our field around those new devices and I
was persuaded that it would allow us to
make a five to ten times improvement and
the performance of the product at lower
cost and to the extent that was true you
can lose of course and that would turn
that be true with most of it not just
give you one example which though it's
easier to understand I think we we had
built for Sylvania direction-finding
system systems free up lay and you put
antennas on the airplane they received
the signal from several different
antennas and then compared the
wavelength and determine the direction
of the signal and for reconnaissance
that's are very important you want to
locate where the signal is located that
was a very important decision the
problem with doing that is that the
signal came to the antenna directly and
also bounced off the wing bounced off
the fuselage about and killing three
threads of it and so you had a confusing
signal and it ended up introducing
substantial errors in your calculation
so we would end up with maybe two or
three degrees error in in location
because of that problem and that
occurred to us that because we were
using digital technology because we had
small computers that could be put right
on the airplane that we could calculate
what those errors would be ahead of time
and compensate for them and correct them
on the fly and by doing that we made
about a factor of 10 improvement and
actually went down a few tenths of a
degrees so once we had done that nobody
wanted to buy direct response systems
for anybody but us codes we were the
only one to do that
which is a simple idea really but it was
the fundamental idea was seizing this
new technology and say how can you apply
it adaptively to this new problem it
wasn't just a matter of replacing vacuum
tubes with semiconductors it was saying
once you endued introduce a time exactly
it's possible to do things you could not
have done otherwise in particular with
the computer that was fast enough that
computers to go on an airplane there was
fast enough to make those calculations
on the fly was was it with the thing
would changed the game and was that the
beginning of the emergence of many
computers from HP and others or was that
even before was it then called the
hp2000 computer which is a dinosaur
today was it was about that big had less
power than one of your laptops today but
still it was a very powerful computer
though today it was fast enough or small
enough that you put on an airplane it
was fast enough to do that job and did
it require for you to have your
businesses at ESL to have counterparts
in the government who actually thought
like you there were a few and you find
them and seek them out and then
encourage it gives plant the eyes are
the these are them let them sell them up
the line now that's a big idea for any
entrepreneurs in the audience as you
find partners at your customer and you
let them take credit for the for the
what geniuses they were if there
anything that you remember in particular
who made a difference I will protect
their identity and some some who were
still being talked about fifty years
late and fifty years later some of the
work I was doing that I just had my book
published about a year ago and before it
publishes I had to submit it to the
Defense Department for review the
classification review they weren't
reviewing the content of whether
anything I was saying the classified
they took out five paragraphs of the
book and to my amazement there was and
had nothing to do with the period when I
was secretary defense it all dealt back
in 1960s and I was doing what things I'm
talking about now the five paragraphs we
were saying things about programs we
were working and then they continued
still fifty years later still classified
Wow and and mordant you think that is I
think it's a bureaucratic ways
they didn't get around to declassify
they should have but also they were very
highly secretive those days very highly
secret it's a I talk about security in
our country like the Hotel California
once you check in you could never check
out and now you were president to the
successful company was growing and and
all of a sudden you get a call from the
US government that says we'd like you to
leave Palo Alto and come to Washington
DC and you different multiple times it
can't be the pay what were you thinking
well what I was thinking was no I don't
want to do that so I got a call from an
old friend his Harold Brown was his name
he had been the president of Cal Tech
and then he had gone back to he was
invited by President Carter become
Secretary of Defense he was a PhD in
physics technical background like myself
and he asked me if I'd come back to be
his undersecretary for research and
engineering and I said no I mean I went
today we talked about entrepreneurs and
serial entrepreneurs people are proud to
say they are a serial entrepreneur I am
proud to say I was not a serial
entrepreneur I might plan a simple and
plain I want to take my company and
build it into great company I had no
idea of bouncing off with another idea
to another company well that was my plan
and then since I was Fuhrman upon the
last thing I want to do is leave my
company and go back to Washington and so
I said no and after two weeks of
protracted discussion back and forth
across the country I yielded and said
yes and which is the right answer by the
way
but what persuaded me to say yes was
this was 1977 now and January 1977 and
the president and secretary carefully
explained to me that we were in a very
serious security issue in those days I
won't bore this class with the whole
security issues of 1977 but they have
some resemblance the security issue
today but when the world war ii ended we
ended up with almost a nuclear monopoly
but we disbanded i we had an army of 10
million men then we just
the army we disbanded a defense industry
the Soviet Union are there Anya and
observing what had happened in world war
two decided they would maintain a large
army and that they would build up a
defense centers they wanted to emulate
what the United States had done in World
War two
they thought the reason the Allies in
one World War two was because of
America's industrial might that's an
oversimplification but certainly was a
major factor in America's industrial
might and they said next war we want to
win with our industrial mind so they
tried to emulate what we had done they
built up this huge defense industry and
maintained quite a large army so in 1977
level with all that background they had
an army about three times the size that
not just we had over it's the NATO had
at that time up until that point we had
said so what we have a great nuclear
advantage but by 1977 had caught up in
nuclear weapons as well everybody was
concerned do it there was serious talk I
think greatly overstated talk about a
window of vulnerability to a surprise
attack by the Soviet there's a lot of
concern and might to the point of
hysteria I would say but in any event
the serious concern when we had to do
something about that and the President
had decided very clearly he did not want
to emulate the third Union into tripling
the size of the military that huge cost
it would be a win to bankrupt our
economy doing that
not to mention fact would be very
politically unpopular so we're not going
to do that we want to offset their
superiority in numbers with a
superiority in technology that's the
magic word
officer offset he went to offset that
and and he's seen what I'd done with the
company and he said what you did was
introduced digital technology into your
particular field it was very successful
I want you to now to introduce digital
technology to all about the most
important military weapons and watch
them and use them then to make them so
much superior to this to the Soviet
weapons that we will offset their
numerical superiority so we we went then
and what came to be called offset
strategy number two the first offset
values we use our nuclear weapons to
offset them the second was to use our
technology to offset them
so he gave me the job to offset and that
was a fascinating job it had about a
hundred billion dollars in your budget
to do that canister which even have you
had to multiply that by ten today to get
the equivalent dollars so there's a lot
of money a lot of resources and he gave
me full authority to do it so that was
just such a fascinating challenge aside
for me an important problem is a
fascinating technical challenge that I
couldn't turn it down so I'm gonna get
into some of the technical challenge but
just for our audience that she for the
Soviet General Staff after you were done
said about the offset strategy there was
revolutionising contemporary warfare and
posed a military threat that the Red
Army couldn't match we cannot equal the
call to us arms for a generation or two
and we'll never be able to catch up with
you and modern arms until we have an
attic economic revolution and the
question is whether we can have an
economic revolution without a political
revolution and I think that answer came
about eight years later I'm surprised
you said it he said it and and you know
a lot of people claim I'm one of the
advocates is that the a second offset
strategy bankrupt that the Soviet Union
because they couldn't follow and and the
demise of communism was due to William
Perry and the second offset strategy but
but this really gets back to what you
observed when you did a ESL that
computers were not just a better version
of X that it was a disruption and a
offset about back then direction-finding
and other intelligent systems and now
you have a national stage to kind of
play this out on what technologies did
you see and choose and why and you know
we talked about sensors and stealth and
precision weapons those are already
ongoing did you select them how did you
invest what did the status quo think
this must have been a heck of a thing it
took about took me about three months to
come up with what the offset strategy
would be it means one things exit we're
gonna use technology three months but
the course is how how how one of the
things we decided right off is we is we
had to make our weapons smart what do we
mean by that well during World War Two
and during the Korean War when we
dropped bombs or fired artillery shells
we never knew exactly where the target
was
and so we had to drop 20 or 30 bombs and
we do anyway and we couldn't guide the
mat koozie we had to drop 20 or 30 bombs
for every target and so we thought what
we went was one bomb one target which
make a huge difference not just in the
actual work but in the logistics tale
that was detailed with it so smart
weapons is one part of it and the
technology was available then led us to
focus primarily on laser-guided bombs
so we built tens of thousands of lasers
we developed and they're built tens of
thousands of laser-guided bomb which are
still today a major fact component of
weapons we needed to have a way of
guiding things accurately and the laser
turned out to be that we also had to
have a better way of knowing where we
were when we fired if you're in an
airplane hood so we thought we'd better
have a way of accurately positioning so
we'd set developed a global positioning
system which is what we call GPS today
and of course everybody uses in the
automobile or in the hand the old
navigator there at the time I wasn't
thinking about the commercial
application that would but the military
applications that we were talking about
Yelp and GPS so we developed GPS at that
time and if and as you used in your car
that you have me to thank for that
we also develop something called ARPANET
and which later became the Internet Wow
and all that was pretty straightforward
and obvious applications of things we
would have been doing that no great leap
forward in imagination just leap forward
technically what was the lead for than
imagination was building us airplane
that could not be detected by radars
you're playing a key component in
military warfare have been since World
War two and because it's so key every
country has developed systems for
shooting them down that involve radars
and and missiles to fire at
surface-to-air missiles which are guided
by radars
so we wanted to develop an airplane that
could not be detected by radars and
therefore they could be not shot down by
missiles and I became because
stealth it's not stealthy and since you
couldn't see it because if the f-117 to
be to flow or when you look up in they'd
be quite obvious to you but the radars
couldn't detect it and so they had
complete impunity at nighttime they
could operate at night without a year so
the stealth was it was a third component
of the those are the three major company
decided in the first three months and
then pull out all of our throttles to
move forward I wanted to have them done
by the end of the I don't want stay more
than one term in government so I want to
have them done in the four year period
indeed we had the first stealth airplane
flying just before I left office and
four years later which is pretty unusual
you don't get that paperwork and usually
have four years ago and so but how did
the status quo treat these programs did
you get our position note the laughs
with the there was a mixture of
reactions to it the the principal
opposition and was really an organized
group which called themselves in the big
group for defense reform or something
there was against introducing technology
in the military on the grounds and in
particular were approached the things we
were doing on the ground that they would
make the weapons too complex for
soldiers to use so complex that it would
break down in the field and that we took
it so complex to be too expensive
neither they had the usability the
reliability and the cost they thought
would be all too high which is - or some
kinds of complex that you introduced in
the system but in fact if you back in
those days they just introduced
something called the hp-35 which is a
hewlett packard handheld calculator
which is about the size of your iPhone
today small iPhone and that machine did
all of the calculations that this
calculator did and a lot more for less
cost it was less costly it was more
reliable and it was easier to operate so
all of the things that they were they
were bringing up against we just in the
opposite direction they mistook
complexity for new technology so the new
technology actually was
cheaper simpler easier to operate and
more reliable reliable than than the old
technology have been and was the
opposition in the military itself or in
Congress or military actors the military
was mixed but it was a lot of people
mill day were hoping we were right and
we're willing to go along with it
most of the opposition came from outside
the military it was very was very it's
really stayed with us for about 10 years
until Desert Storm the first test of
this new technology came in 1989 I guess
it was almost 10 years later after he
developed all this stuff and Desert
Storm the f-117 - of a Baghdad a
thousand times I mean of a thousand
sorties over Baghdad Baghdad at that
time was the most heavily defended city
in the world they had hundreds of modern
soviet-built surface-to-air missiles and
in those thousand sorties there wasn't a
single rear plane shot down alone no-one
they flew him all night they should have
done and they and there were thousands
and thousands of rounds fired at them in
every other one so a thousand missions
and no airplanes shut down so this the
self worked like a charm
they carried laser-guided bombs and we
talked about here and two thousand
thousand authorities dropped two
thousand bombs ad percent of the made
direct hits on the target which again
was an unprecedented level of accuracy
from that point on nobody in the
military doubted the effects of it and
the critics who just sort of disappeared
they stopped talking and a rare
opportunity to prove enough to prove a
new technology in such an in such a
dramatic setting Wow
that's you know if the story ended there
that would be an incredible life but you
had a almost a second career in
diplomacy which is the opposite of
preparing for Wars of actually waging
peace and you did a
just an amazing story there but before I
get off on diplomacy I didn't want to
ask you a question is we were talking
earlier before we came on about there's
now a search for a third offset strategy
and and and maybe we could talk about
that for a minute or two and then we
talk about diplomacy why are people
searching for why is the US government
searching for third offset strategy and
go back to Desert Storm it was we were
facing really the fifth largest army in
the world and four thousand miles away
from our home bases and they were
defeated they were routed in five days
and that made a huge impression profound
impression on militaries all over the
world so all of the other military said
what can we do about that and the two
obvious choices one of them is we try to
emulate it which is not so easy if you
don't have the technology base in the
first place or we can try to work around
it work around it means we invent
something called a symmetric warfare
and the nations are where the smartest
the adversaries of the spars went to add
a symmetrical warfare and can you give
us an example
basically yeah urban guerilla warfare
none of the things I've talked about
under the technology I don't have any
relevance to that so why should they
fight us and things were good at
fighting things were not good at huh the
intelligence systems don't work in an
urban guerrilla setting the intelligence
in the to the benefit of the grill is
not to not to this other way around so
that was rerouted so we I think became
overconfident we thought this because we
had this capability for defeating an
army in the field that we could do an
army Lee could do anything I wanted to
and so the second Iraq war came and we
had a head handed to us in my opinion
now we quickly defeated the Iraqi army
the second time around just like the
first time around but that turned out
that wasn't the real war the real war
ends up being fought in the cities it
was an urban guerrilla war and we did
very poorly Annette so began to dawn on
people that the military has to be
tailored to deal with what the threat
actually is not what we would like it to
be
and that the military had designed to
fight attack warfare in the desert
wasn't that wasn't the problem we're
going to be facing and so now that
people think we need a new offset
strategy to deal with these new kinds of
threats the new threat to different in
nature their guerrilla warfare their
cyber warfare and there might be
conflict in space you can think of three
or four or five possible threats to a
military for which the the army we build
in notes a we built isn't it isn't
really appropriate so when the new
Secretary of Defense Command of a year
and a half ago did ash Carter who had
been by the way my assistant secretary
when I was secretary defense and who was
very familiar with all this offset
strategy saw another PhD another PhD
physical physique biscuit active PhD
within its theoretical physics and
Renaissance literature he's a real
renaissance man so he decided he was
going to try to introduce offset
strategy three and it just got started a
few months ago and one of he's been one
of the things he did to realize out to
recognizing the importance of digital
technology and information technology
what he wanted to do was he set up an
office out here until Lagaan Valley
it's called di UX which means what
defense innovation innovation unit
experimental yeah and and so do you
think he found it is there a third
offset strategy yet I don't know it's a
tough job it was it only took us three
months to come up with what we wanted to
do in the last time around but in
retrospect was a lot easier job and what
he's facing now he's they've been
working on this for six months now and
have not yet come up with the concrete
to try because back then we had one
nation-state facing us which was Soviet
Union with conventional land and it was
easier to think of it was easy to
describe wasn't so hard to deal with it
was easy to describe anyway this one's
not quite sure now we have non nation
states we have nation states we have
yeah
so it's kind of Messier it's a very
different problem he's and I think it
much more difficult public that he's
facing and technology may will play an
important role in dealing with but
certainly not the only role and he's
trying to figure out how to tailor the
technology to deal with those particular
problems that's not the opposite
strategy three it's all about God and so
that kind of gets us segues into almost
the second career were new we're
starting here first and that it was
diplomacy and I remember President
Carter actually we kind of put you on
some diplomatic missions at the time for
diplomatic negotiations with China as
well as Israel and Egypt following the
Camp David agreements how do you feel
about you know taking out his expanded
role did you think of yourself as a
negotiator that was there some manual
they gave you to figure out how to do
that I didn't think there's anything
special about negotiating with people
that you have to think of what what
they're trying to achieve where they're
coming from and listen to them just
wanting to learn that the to the extent
is an art in negotiation it comes on in
the brilliant things you say but how
carefully you listen
and so diplomacy to me at least a big
part of it is listening to what others
will say I'm trying to figure out how to
accommodate them can you give me an
example
that's an interesting insight can you is
there anything you remember that struck
you that no one was hearing and you well
when I was secretary we had a tragic
situation in Bosnia whether it's sort of
a civil war going on there between the
Bosnian Muslims and the Bosnian Serbs
and hundreds of thousands of people
being killed and millions this place and
put it in one concentration camp it
wasn't it and it was the worst atrocity
since World War two really and the NATO
peacekeeping mission have been tending
there to deal with it was totally it out
of what they couldn't handle it so
finally NATO decided to send in the NATO
force to bring order of the country and
to and to stop the killing and then get
to people get back to their homes
and the problem one of the problems in
doing this with the NATO readily agreed
to do that and the United States was
were leading the the mission but there
was Russia and Russia is a Slavic
country and Serbia is a sloppy country
and they there's a there's a brotherhood
relation between them really and so they
wanted they they were they were by God
send in a brigade also while having a
brigade of Russians and a brigade of
American that never gated British under
different commands fighting a war seemed
like a very recipe for disaster that's
what we're doing in Syria by the way
today but there was a bigger larger
scale going on in Bosnia then so
President Clinton and President then
Yeltsin agreed that we were to have a
unified force they didn't know how to do
it but he said we ought to have one and
they turned to their defense minister
myself and the gates of Clinton and and
administered watch off in the case of
Russia and said solve this problem find
a way of bringing these forces under one
command and so that was my my greatest
exercise in negotiation I think I'll do
solve the problem because then I heard
the word that I heard most to another
negotiation was nyet yeah over and over
again and it took us four meetings
really over a period of two months we
had two months to solve it and I met
once in Geneva once in Washington once
in a white man air force base and then
finally once in Brussels and the finally
the the third third meeting we got a
formula for solution and the fourth
meeting we signed it but it was a crap
question listening in to what was really
bugging groschopp why he didn't want to
do that we finally ended up he put his
brigade one of his best brigades
reporting to an american division
commander Wow drive brigades in our to
one of our divisions he did not want to
report into NATO he was willing to have
a report to an American commander Wow
and it took me about it and I'm a slow
learner took me three meetings and
provide figured that out that's what was
really bugging him when we finally got a
solution to it but it's listening to the
other people
well and that segways begin to something
you said in your book which I about
Russia which I thought was just a little
sobering if I got it right you said that
in less than fifteen years the
relationship between the US and Russia
went from being quite positive to an
all-time low and you listed a series of
policy decisions that we've made that
you believe contributed to the
deterioration of relationships and I
won't list them all but what do you
think we should be doing is it is there
anything solvable with Putin or is it
some of it on us or the many significant
problems were facing today that seem to
be getting worse on a month-by-month
basis and I I don't think we can solve
any one of those problems but just by
attacking that problem we had to get at
the underlying issue which is the
hostility between the United States and
Russia today I think nothing can be
solved without addressing that problem
directly and that has to be done at the
highest level it has to be present
present to deal with that and that's not
happening it's not likely to happen in
the near future because based on their
experiences with each other President
Putin and President Obama do not like
each other at all to say they hate each
other maybe too strong but hate to be in
the same room with each other a bad
situation and I think each of them ought
to be able to sort of get over that and
work for the common interest but that
may or may not happen
what iein several other senator nunn
have proposed is that we at least go to
Russia was the proposal that we form a
working team high-level working team to
deal with the problem of nuclear
terrorism which is an equally a danger
to Russia as it is to the United States
and find a way of working together on
that one problem if we can do that if we
can succeed on that one problem then
maybe we can work off a broader base of
cooperation so for the president's job
is to define those areas where we can
cooperate and try to make that
cooperation happen
dental ID the other problems where we
have completely hostile and not going to
cooperate and sort of isolate that and
minimize the day and even though come
from those that's an interesting way to
think I just got smarter right there but
find the areas of common interest there
must be between nations day long
Oh certainly certainly the new danger
nuclear terrorism and I want a nuclear
bomb it's like the go off in mosque in
Moscow as it is in Washington I do want
to spend time on that but but let's just
take what you said about Russia finding
common interest is the same true for
China every relationships are
deteriorated and we need to find some
common interest or is there different
issues going on there ask me that yeah
are there different issues that are
going on with China than there are with
Russia at all yes a huge difference
between the US China versus US Russia as
we have a very profound economic
relationship with China huge trades
bilateral traders with China exchange of
Technology there are many many common
interests we have with China every
reason every objective reason said that
the United States and China ought to be
working together on the friendly basis
in cooperation to advance the common
interests of both countries and to a
large degree that has been happening but
has have been notable exceptions in the
last few years which worried me a lot
which ones are though well the most
obvious ones are the know back up a
little bit though where it was earlier a
major problem over Taiwan and we worked
very hard I think I worked when I was in
office I worked on I was out of office
and the president worked very hard to
resolve that problem I think today
Taiwan has gone away as an issue between
the United States of China that it's
very unlikely that it would be a war
between China and Taiwan that might drag
the United States into it and the that's
a separate issue and I don't want
discuss it right now but good things
have been done that area to eat to
mitigate that problem I think about more
recently the problems that come up in
the South China Sea and there's a
clearly clear difference of perception
between the United States and China
about what the South China Sea is we
look at his international waters where
our ships couldn't pass freely and some
in China regarded sort of a Chinese lake
and that they have rights to and we have
rights to keep American ships planes out
of so on the difference is a very good
not just for the United States for the
Philippines and with Vietnam Taiwan all
of those countries but particularly the
Philippines I think and and Vietnam have
major disputes with China over the
rights a violent rights on that and
there in the South China Sea with
respect to ownership of islands with
respect to right drilling rights and so
on so there are big big disputes for
maybe a decade between Vietnam and China
and between Philippines and China the
United States was taken off the side
take look all we care about is we don't
we want these issues to be resolved
peaceably and we want to maintain
selling rights steaming rights through
the through the South China Sea this was
brought been being brought to a head
there by the Chinese starting to build
air bases on some of those are on making
a reef and build an artificial island
putting an airbase on it and that's
leading I think to some kind of a
showdown which I'm very concerned about
and and do you think the Chinese looking
for a showdown or it doesn't think
they'll get one it doesn't make sense I
mean it it doesn't make sense but I
don't I have to say I fully do not fully
understand what's behind the new Chinese
president who it's a very different very
different leader than than his
predecessors have been all the way
combed all the way back to today well
since 1983 84 all the leadership isn't
working towards a cooperation with the
United States and not making waves on
territorial issues but I don't know I
just don't know I can't say can't really
say where this new leader is headed but
it would be a huge mistake I'd be a
tragic mistake if the United States and
China where to get in some sort of a
military conflict over the you who are
these relatively minor issues on on
ownership or who owns this reef
if they seem to be symbolic of something
they're symbolic of something bigger for
China there's certainly symbolic and the
underlying symbolic issue would try to
think I think has been their righteous
grievance over the abused they took 400
years by western part mostly not not the
United States but mostly European powers
and they're they call a century of
humiliation that's a that's a serious
issue in China and that's one which they
have rights I said a righteous grievance
but now they bring that forward into the
modern day that thinking for it into the
modern day I think it could lead to
mischeif and and then let me segue from
China a bit to something else you were
personally and deeply involved with
which was North Korea in fact if I
remember you stated we were this close
to having an agreement in 2000 and then
five years later we were facing a
nuclear-armed North Korea because of
some policy decisions that have been
made on someone else's watch are you
optimistic or pessimistic I'm passive
I'm pessimistic right now how do you
think that's gonna be huh we had we've
had problems in North Korea many times
in the last thirty years all over their
aspirations have nuclear weapons and up
until year 2000 we were able to hold off
those aspirations and I went to
Pyongyang and met with the leadership in
North Korea do we at the request of
President Clinton in 1999 I guess it was
I was out of office by the time he asked
me to go over is his personal long way
to deal with North Koreans and I made a
proposal to them whereby the United
States would recognize them as a whole
kind we do not have it we don't wreck
today we don't have an embassy in their
country for example we'd recognize them
we're just give them technical
assistance got both South Korean Japan
to get an economic assistance and in
return they would give up their nuclear
weapon program and long-range missile
and we were very close to a deal I think
President Clinton was ready to sign the
deal
he said they sent a senior military
person over to meet in Washington said
they were ready to sign the deal and
funny thing happened was an election of
new administration come in in 2000
election of 2000 emancipation in January
2001 I was not too much concerned I'm
sorry that we hadn't gotten it done
ahead of time before the election but it
we didn't and talked with Colin Powell
who was the incoming Secretary of State
he said not to worry we'll bring this
deal took it to conclusion and two
months later the South Korean president
came back to meet with President Bush
and President Bush said by cutting off
all discussion on North Korea and for
two years there was no contact at all
next thing we knew they were starting to
build nuclear weapons that's it I've
over simplified a complicated story but
that's I think we made a major misstep
there I think we could have stopped the
program now I don't see any good way of
stopping it they have a dozen maybe more
of nuclear weapons they're building more
fissile material
they're testing long-range missiles are
testing submarine missiles so I think we
let ourselves in for another necess
serious unnecessary problem and do you
think they might be a prolific writer as
well there was do you think they might
be pool operating nuclear weapons
they're certainly a proliferator there's
been two ways between them and Pakistan
some of their technology came from
Pakistan and they have also assisted
Pakistan they sold a nuclear reactor to
Libya an apartment a theory I mean to
Syria which the Israelis obliged the
Syria the Libyans by by the syrian by
bombing so it doesn't exist anymore but
they came from North Korea really yeah
which was a not not legal going on that
high note
you've been George salts and Henry
Kissinger and Sam Nunn are still working
to reduce the nuclear threat you tell us
about why you're doing that in
what you want to see happen in 2006
October 2006 mm-hmm with the 20th
anniversary of the Reykjavik summit some
of you may have never heard of the
Reykjavik summit but in one of President
Reagan's I think most period diplomatic
strokes he met with the then President
Gorbachev of Russia and they the Iceland
capital of Reykjavik and they talked for
two days without notes without aids
except secretary Schultz who was there
about the idea of giving up nuclear
weapons altogether unique and
unprecedented a boat that was ready in
the end they could not come to an
agreement but they talked about they did
not come to an agreement and just twenty
years before the anniversary of that
George sure said why don't we have a
Stanford conference seminar or the
conference on the Reykjavik summit
revisited 20 years later what were the
lessons from the Reykjavik summit and so
we did in 2006 and the conclusion of
that seminar Stanford was that we ought
to revisit the idea of eliminating
nuclear weapons and shorts and Sam Nunn
who is here myself and then we lay got
Henry Kissinger to join us banded up to
write an op-ed for The Wall Street
Journal which said just that number one
nuclear weapons today are more of a
danger than they are an age of security
number two there'll always be a danger
until we find a way to eliminate them
and in the meantime we ought to find
ways of reducing their danger that was
the essence of the op-ed and it caused
quite a stir not because the ideas were
so new but because the ideas are coming
from for people who are certified cold
warriors I mean I'd help build up this
nuclear arsenal as head shorts and has
had none in his role as head of the
Senate Armed Services Committee as
Kissinger as sectors
so you were now a bunch of radicals so
this was a dramatic statement coming
from these four people it caused quite a
stir in the international community it
and it actually caused some progress
along that line for a number of years
the most dramatic progress came when
President Obama was elected in 2008
because just two months after he's
inaugurated he went to Prague gave his
first international speech as a
president which among other things he
said I state with conviction the
intention of the United States to seek
if he can because the peace and security
of a world without nuclear weapons
there's a stunning statement coming to a
president of the United States in
underworld and for a couple of years
after that we actually read progress in
that direction we had made another Armus
treaty with the Russians where we each
agreed to reduce nuclear weapons I think
when the most important things the
president did he started something
called the nuclear summits where the 50
nations that have pissah material
because scimitar is what it takes to
make a nuclear weapon but it's also used
to run nuclear reactors 50 nations have
that pistol murderer came together and
pound agreed on improved ways of
controlling that fissile material could
not fall into the hands of a terrorist
so for about I'd say four or five years
a lot of good progress made now there's
been a retrogression the retrogression I
think sinks almost completely with the
growing are still early between the US
and Russia because Russia then said I we
don't want to have any more are
mistreated we know anymore I'm gonna go
she aged with the United States and they
started building a whole new round of
nuclear weapons United States now
decides we need to build a whole new
round of nuclear weapons so we have the
Cold War and nuclear arms race starting
all over again so we're moving backwards
now well I'm not sure he knows but but
before we take some questions from the
audience the last question for you is
what role can stamp
students entrepreneurs play in solving
national security problems engineering
or policy problems what can students
know in the case of my example I didn't
even start addressing these problems for
twice - twenty or so years into my
career but what I had done in my career
which is a technical career to not be a
huge hugely important backgrounds what I
ended up doing so even if you have this
aspiration you have to move directly to
it you move to developing your skills so
that when you do decide to direct them
to security from the government problems
you have those skills already but beyond
that if you want to address the issue
today I'd say the first thing you need
to do is understand what the issues are
take the time to study and understand
what the issues are the many sources are
available for you to do that including
courses at Stanford so the first issue
is get to get smart on the issues then
the second if you've done that is start
to involve other people your friends
your colleagues your family in the issue
spread the word because the reason we
are slipping into another Cold War into
another nuclear arms race is because the
people in this country do not understand
the dangers or what's underway or why
does it what has happened now is about
to happen it's already in process of
happening and so we have to have a
better educated populace towards it
I mean it's you have a sort of delayed
gratification and saying education but
you have to educate yourself that's the
first step and you have to help educate
others if we be if we become an informed
citizenry then we'll take informed
intelligent actions we are not today an
informed citizenry on this problem ok
well thank you mr. secretary what I'd
like to do is take at least a question
or two before we before we end who has a
question yes
I was not curious I came a little bit
late so I hope you didn't talk about
this is very beginnings but could that
third edge or whatever could it be
something related to like cyber security
and could you talk about cyber security
so the question is can cyber security be
one of the third one of the components
of a third offset strategy cyber
security is one of them it important one
of the most important components of the
third officer Trey already that are
already pretty well established yes good
question great question other questions
going once
cyber security is an ass symmetric
warfare really fit because question
about the Zika virus yeah and the
Olympics and what's the question
thoughts on the Zika virus in the
Olympics Tom do you have any thoughts on
Zika virus is a national security issue
or is a security I don't know any more
about the Vico virus than you do but
what I read about it it sounds like a
serious problem other questions yes so
the question is how do you see
iranian-american relationships going
forward I think the the agreement was
made with Iran on their nuclear program
is it was unnecessary but not a
sufficient condition first tablished
good relationships it was certainly
necessary it poor it poisonous Austin to
poison Iran to try to work together in a
more cooperative and friendly manner
so it's possible now for that to happen
and I hope it can happen there was a lot
of opposition in the United States are
you to do it to read the newspapers to
understand a lot of people not only
don't want that cooperative relationship
but they didn't even want them did the
nuclear deal there's a lot of opposition
to it
there's also a lot of Opposition in a
man to it we've got our side job
but the Iran revolutionary good guard is
entirely opposed to the deal and they
want to go ahead and build nuclear
weapons they're very very clear about
that
so there's a big opposition of both
countries who will prevail remains to be
seen one can hope that in the United
States at least it will would it will
move forward trying to seek a positive
relation with Iran the last time I
visited and I should say I've met four
times or the Iranian officials see now
wonder now the Foreign Minister and the
National Security Advisor talking about
this problem just trying to see if I
could this is before we actually start
negotiating see if I could find a what
foothold for our negotiators on this and
I was persuaded that we could find we
could make a deal with him although the
deal we ended up with I was able to
better more favorable than what I
thought was yet I also visited Iran and
a number of times most recently is a
tourist and met with a lot of Iranians
there's a wellspring of good feeling for
Americans among Iranian whatever the
government says it does there's a there
really is a basis I think for a positive
relationship so I'm truly hoping we can
get something going positive with a
random yet it's stupid for us to be at
loggerheads with Iran well mr. secretary
I I got smart drew this last hour so
thank you very much